so I come from the tallest people on the
planet the Dutch it hasn't always been
this way in fact all across the globe
people have been gaining height in the
last hundred and fifty years in
developed countries on average we have
gotten 10 centimetres taller and
scientists have a lot of theories about
why this is but almost all of them
involve nutrition maybe the increase of
dairy and meat in the last 50 years
global meat consumption has more than
quadrupled from 71 million tons to 210
million tonnes
something similar has been going on with
milk and eggs in every society where
incomes have risen so as protein
consumption and we know that globally we
are getting richer and as similar
classes on the rise so is our global
population from 7 billion of us today
29.7 billion by 2050 which means that by
2050 we are going to need at least 70%
more protein than what is available to
humankind today and the latest
prediction of the UN puts that
population number by the end of the
century at 11 billion which means that
we are going to need a lot more protein
this challenge is staggering so much so
that recently a team at NBA Vasquez
global sustainability Institute
suggested that if we don't change our
global policies and food production
systems our societies might actually
collapse in the next 30 years currently
our ocean serves as the main source of
animal protein over 2.6 billion people
depend on it every single day at the
same time our global fisheries are two
and a half times larger the model oceans
can sustainably support meaning that
human state far more fish from the ocean
than the oceans can naturally replace
WWF recently published a report showing
that just in the last 40 years a global
marine life has been slashed in half and
another recent report suggests that of
largest predatory species such as
swordfish and bluefin tuna over 90
percent has disappeared since the 1950s
there are a lot of great sustainable
fishing initiatives across the planets
working towards better
and better manage fisheries but
ultimately all of these initiatives are
working towards keeping current catch
constants it's unlikely even with the
best manage fisheries that we are going
to be able to take much more from the
ocean than we do today we have to stop
plundering our oceans the way we have we
need to alleviate the pressure on it and
we are at a point where if you push much
harder for more produce we might face
total collapse occurrence systems are
not going to feed a growing global
population so how do we fix this what's
the world going to look like in just 35
short years when there's 2.7 billion
more of us sharing the same resources we
could all become vegan sounds like a
great idea but it's not realistic and
it's impossibly hard to mandate globally
people are eating animal protein whether
we like it or not
I suppose we fail to change our ways and
continue on the current path failing to
meet demands the World Health
Organization recently reported at 800
million people are suffering from
malnutrition and food shortage which is
due to that same growing global
population and a declining access to
resources like water energy and land it
takes very little imagination to picture
a world of global unrest riots and
further malnutrition people are hungry
and we are running dangerously low on
natural resources for so so many reasons
we need to change our global food
production systems we must do better and
there is a solution and that solution
lies in aquaculture
the farming of fish plants like seaweed
shellfish and crustaceans as the great
ocean hero Jacques Cousteau once said we
must start using the ocean as farmers
instead of hunters that's what
civilization is all about farming
instead of hunting fish is the last food
that we hunt and why is it that we keep
hearing phrases like life's too short
for farmed fish or wild-caught of course
of a fish that we know virtually nothing
about we don't know what it ate during
its lifetime and we don't know what
pollution has encountered if it was a
large predatory species might have gone
through the course of Fukushima
yesterday we don't know very few people
realize that trace
ability and Fisheries never goes beyond
the hunter that caught the wild animal
but let's back up for a second and talk
about why fish is the best food choice
it's healthy it prevents heart disease
it provides key amino acids and key
fatty acids like a mega trees which is
very different from almost any other
type of meat and aside from being
healthy it's also a lot more exciting
and diverse think about it most animal
farming is pretty monotonous cows cow
sheep a sheep pigs pick and pull the
turkey duck chicken pretty much sums it
up and then there's 500 species of fish
being fond currently not that Western
supermarkets reflect that on the shelves
but that's beside the point
and you can farm fish in a very healthy
manner that's good for us good for the
planet and good for the fish I know why
some fish obsessed
let me explain my billion partner and
wife Amy Novogratz and I got involved in
aquaculture a couple of years ago we
were inspired by Silverio we won the top
prize in 2009 we actually met a mission
blue one in the Galapagos um amy was
there's the TED Prize director million
entrepreneur from the Netherlands
concerned citizen love to dive a passion
for the oceans mission blue truly
changed our lives we fell in love got
married and we came away really inspired
thinking we really want to do something
around ocean conservation something that
was meant to last that could make a real
difference and and something that we
could do together
little did we expect that that would
lead us to fish farming but a few months
after we got off the boats we got to a
meeting at a Conservation International
where the director-general of world fish
was talking about aquaculture asking a
roomful of environmentalists to stop
turning from it realize what was going
on and to really get involved because
aquaculture has the potential to be just
what our oceans and populations need he
was stunned from you heard the stats
that we didn't know more about this
industry already and excited about the
chance to help get it right to talk
about stats right now the amount of fish
consumed globally and wild catch and
combines is twice the tonnage of the
total amount of beef produced on planet
earth last year every single fishing
vessel combined small and large across
the globe together produce about 65
million tons of wild caught seafood for
human consumption
aquaculture this year for the first time
in history actually produces more than
what we catch from the wealth but now
this demand is going to go up in the
next 35 years we are going to need an
additional 85 million tonnes to meet
demand which is one and a half times as
much almost as what we catch globally
out of our oceans an enormous number
it's safe to assume that that's not
going to come from the ocean it needs to
come from farming and talk about farming
and for farming you need resources as a
human needs to eat to grow and stay
alive so does an animal a cow needs to
eat eight to nine pounds of feed and
drink almost 8,000 liters of water to
create just one pound of meat experts
agree that is impossible to farm cows
for every inhabitant on this planet we
just don't have enough feed or water
we can't keep cutting down rainforests
for it and fresh water planet Earth has
a very limited supply we need something
more efficient to keep humankind alive
on this planet and now let's compare
that with fish farming you can farm one
pound of fish with just one pound of
feed and depending on species even less
and why is that
well that's because fish first of all
floats it doesn't need to stand around
all day resisting gravity like we do and
most fish is cold-blooded
it doesn't need to heat itself fish
kills and it needs very little water
which is counterintuitive
but as we say it swims in it but it
hardly drinks it fish is the most
resource efficient animal protein
available to humankind
aside from insects how much we've
learned since for example that on top of
that 65 million tons that's annually
caught for human consumption
there's an additional 30 million tons
caught for animal feed mostly sardines
anchovies for the aquaculture industry
that's turned into fish meal of fish oil
and this is madness 65 percent of these
fisheries globally are badly managed
some of the worst issues of our time are
connected to it it's destroying our
oceans the worst slavery issues
imaginable are connected to it recently
an article came out of Stanford saying
that if 50% of the world's aquaculture
industry would stop using fish meal our
oceans would be saved I think about that
for a minute now we know that the oceans
have far more problems and air pollution
as acidification coral reef destruction
and so on but it underlines the impact
of our fisheries and it underlines how
interconnected everything is fisheries
aquaculture deforestation climate change
food security and so on in the search
for alternatives the industry at a
massive scale has reverted to land-based
alternatives like soy industrial chicken
waste blood meal from slaughterhouses
and so on and we understand where these
choices come from but this is not the
right approach it's not sustainable it's
not healthy have you ever seen a chicken
at the bottom of the ocean of course not
if you feed salmon soy with nothing else
it literally explodes salmon is a
carnivore there's no way to digest soy
now fish farming is by far the best
animal farming available to humankind
but has had a really bad reputation has
been excessive use of chemicals has been
virus and disease transferred to wild
populations ecosystem destruction and
pollution escaped fish breeding with
wild populations altering the overall
genetic pool and then of course as just
mentioned and the unsustainable feed
ingredients how blessed were the days
when we could just enjoy food that was
on our plate whatever it was once you
know you know you can't go back it's not
fun we really need a transparent food
system that we can trust that produces
healthy food but the good news is that
decades of development and research have
led to a lot of new technologies and
knowledge that allow us to do a lot
better
we can now farm fish without any of
these issues
I think of agriculture before the Green
Revolution we are at aquaculture and
blue revolution new technologies means
that we can now produce a feed that's
perfectly natural with a minimum
footprints that consists of microbes
insects seaweeds and microalgae LT for
the people healthy for the fish healthy
for the planet microbes for example can
be a perfect alternative for high grade
fish meal at scale insects and well
first of all the perfect recycling
because they've grown on food waste a
bit second a think of fly fishing and
you know our logical it actually is to
use it as fish feed you don't need large
tracts of lands for it and you don't
need to cut down rainforests for it and
microbes and insects are actually net
water producers this revolution is
starting as we speak it just needs scale
we can now farm far more species than
ever before in controlled natural
conditions create happy fish I imagine
for example a closed system that's about
performing more efficient than insect
farming where you can produce healthy
happy delicious fish with little or no
effluent almost no energy and almost no
water and a natural feed with a minimal
footprint or a system where you grow up
to ten species next to each other off of
each other mimicking nature you need
very little feet very little footprint
I think of seaweed growing off the
effluent of fish for example does great
technologies popping up all over the
globe from alternatives to battle
disease so we don't need antibiotics and
chemicals anymore - automated feeders
that feel when the fish are hungry so we
can save on feed and create less
pollution software systems the gathered
data across farms so we can improve farm
practises there's really cool stuff
happening all over the globe and make no
mistake all of these things are possible
at a cost that's competitive to what a
farmer spends today tomorrow there will
be no excuse for anyone to not do the
right thing so somebody needs to connect
the dots
and give these developments a big kick
in the butt and that's what we've been
working on the last couple of years and
that's what we need to be working on
together rethinking everything from the
ground up with a holistic view across
the value chain connecting all these
things across the globe alongside great
entrepreneurs and that are willing to
share a collective vision now is the
time to create change in this industry
and to push it into a sustainable
direction this industry is still young
much of his quote is still ahead it's a
big task but not as far-fetched as you
might think it's possible so we need to
take pressure of the ocean we want to
eat good and healthy and if we eat an
animal it needs to be one that had a
happy and healthy life we need to have a
meal that we can trust live long lives
and this is not just for people in San
Francisco or Northern Europe this is for
all of us even in the poorest countries
it's not just about money people prefer
something fresh and healthy that they
can trust over something and that comes
from far away that they know nothing
about we're all the same the day will
come where people will realize that
demand found fish on the plate that's
farmed well and that's farmed healthy
and if use anything less you can help
speed this up ask questions when you
want to seafood where does my fish come
from who raised it and what did it eat
information about where your fish comes
from and how it was produced need to be
much more readily available and
consumers need to be put pressure on the
aquaculture industry to do the right
thing so every time you order ask for
detail and show that you really care
about what you eat and what's been given
to you and eventually they will listen
and all of us will benefit thank you